i've been dreaming about this my whole  life today's treasure that's never been  found  five billion easy  oh my god i'm so sorry  hey you're still with me  500 years ago my family found the  fortune then was betrayed  so much blood  pretty sure he's just threatening to  kill me don't touch your ear like that  you look like an idiot uncharted  exclusively in movie theaters  it's the biggest treasure that's never  been found  five billion easy on february 18th my  family has been looking for this person  for a very long time so much blood tom  holland  oh my god get about to get a proper  scottish welcome  what  [Music]  tom holland and mark wahlberg in  uncharted we better get smaller in your  case smaller they're only like one inch  taller than me it's a little more than  that kid exclusively in movie theaters  february 18th  you